any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
doctor soon to be professor sarah
cameron welcome to the into the
impossible podcast how are you today
i'm doing great thank you for having me
so great to have you i just
absolutely devoured your book audiobook
which is an audible exclusive we're
going to talk a lot about that
and i want to just read a brief bio if i
read the whole bio you're so impressive
sarah that it will take the whole hour
that you have generously and graciously
and allotted me but currently you're
sarah rugheimer is an astrophysicist at
oxford working on how to detect life on
an exoplanet by look exoplanet
atmospheric biosignatures
uh in 2020 she was selected as a ted
fellow
and she has a wonderful ted talk which
has been seen by almost a million people
in just a couple of weeks and you can
find that it's called searching for
microscopic aliens i'll put a link to
that here maybe we'll put some highlight
they do a great job and your wonderful
audiobook is an amazon audible original
searching for extraterrestrial life and
i wanted to start there with amazon
because as you know today was the first
voyage of the new shepherd
spacecraft piloted by the proprietor of
amazon uh mr jeff bezos and his brother
and uh an astronaut named wally
funk who was uh one of the original
mercury 13 i think
and uh so there was life in space for a
little bit today and actually
i want to get your impression about
where
we should be going if you look at aliens
looking at us today they would have seen
you know four people heading towards
them uh so uh first of all what uh what
do you make of this
hmm that's that's an interesting
question i kind of view them as separate
and in some ways a bit contradictory uh
so i'm really excited about wally funk
you know she's the oldest uh astronaut
now 82 years old part of the mercury 13
program really excited for her to have
lived out that lifelong dream
uh
and then there's this tension though
because we have you know people from the
private sector who can just put whatever
they want into space say um you know
like satellites and uh you know the the
is it the starlink from from elon musk
and and whatnot and i would say there's
some tension then between the scientific
community and how that would influence
our observations or what i'm worried
about as an astrobiologist is i really
i'm pro-human exploration of space
absolutely we're explorers i do i climb
mountains i climb mountains just because
they're there
um i am definitely pro-human space
exploration on the long term but i'm
really worried that we're going to screw
up our ability to
study the red planet especially mars if
we send humans there prematurely so if
we go there before we can actually
explore it to see if there was life or
if there is current life under the
subsurface if we instead contaminate it
with you know us and all the hearty
microbes we bring from earth that would
be something i feel like we have one and
you know one chance to actually do
so this month we've had on several
different scientists
from around the planet talking about
life entropy the origin of life
and and even the definition of life so
as somebody who searches for life first
question i have for you is the eternal
question that erwin schrodinger
mean i go back to nasa's working
definition because it is just very
convenient of course we don't really
know because we're still hampered by the
one example of life that we have on
earth which is earth life uh so you know
this idea of a self-sustained
chemical system capable of undergoing
darwinian evolution there's a few very
broad things i like about that
definition one of them being
that it is chemical that it can evolve
and uh you know that
those things i think are are interesting
however what if we come across
you know artificial intelligence that's
quote unquote past that might be alive
that life would not be included under
that definition
and when we think about um you know the
yeah as max tegmar calls life 3.0
artificial intelligence uh what do you
make of the fact that we've been very
much focused literally and figuratively
in some cases my colleague professor
shelly wright here searching for optical
signals from seti uh from advanced
extraterrestrial intelligence
what about this predilection that mostly
seti has been about looking for
technology or techno signatures is that
just because
that you kind of look for your keys
under the lamp post as the old joke goes
or do should we pay more attention to
the kinds of signals signatures that you
look on from the tiniest aliens in the
universe
well in the short answer is we should do
both i don't think they're that's at
odds with each other
certainly i think we have if you look at
the history of life on earth life has
been on earth basically as soon as earth
was habitable we have signs of life
dating back very dating back very far in
earth's history and then it was single
cellular for most of earth's history and
it's really only in the last you know
billion years that it's been more than
one celled type of life and then even
just in the last 100 years that it's
been technological
us
and so
you know when we think of earth as a
if it is a representative planet for
most time we would have seen the
microbial biosphere so i think that is
our best chance for finding life in the
solar in the universe sorry not the
solar system also in the solar system i
think we might find microbial life but
in the in the universe and other planets
uh however we should also search for
intelligence signals because that is
definitely a clearer signal if someone
waves at you and says hello we are here
then you know you found life whereas i
think we're going to argue a lot
yeah so we're going to get to venus in
just a little bit because your book is
timely it's topical uh it's very much at
the cutting edge of what we know your
audio book
which we'll have links to in the
description
but
i want to first take a step back in your
past world line where you come from or
where you've been
you're from montana you make no secret
of that you mention it with a great deal
of montana pride i know most of what i
know about montana from the tv show
yellowstone uh so and i i hope that's
not representative that's kind of like
sopranos move from new jersey and go to
montana but if you haven't seen it
but the other thing i think about
montana a lot is like looking for
fossils and dinosaurs and so forth and i
want to ask you know was that part of
what's in your intellectual dna this
search for for ancient signals did that
arise in part because of your unique the
unique place that you came from bozeman
montana town of what 50 000 people what
are the odds that somebody becomes a
searcher for alien artifacts perhaps
fossil light
don't think it did though one in
hindsight one could see how you might
describe that so my dad was a physics
professor at montana state university
and in fact we did he would uh do talks
for the local museum
and then they would send us on dinosaur
digs in the summer for free like that
was his exchange with with the museum
and so you know as a kid i did go out
into eastern montana and just you know
try to use
like little brushes and and chisels to
see if i could find dinosaur bones found
a few it was exciting
i didn't become a paleontologist you
know and and then in the end i didn't
even want to be
a physicist so my dad was a physics
professor my brother is also a physics
professor
all of all of his children have a degree
in physics of some sort and so i really
told my dad i was like i'm never ever
gonna take a physics class as long as i
live i hope you're okay with that and my
dad was always supportive he's like you
gotta major in what you want to major in
and so i don't know i think i was going
in
thinking about robotic engineering you
know in in my first year at a community
college in montana and then i looked
back well i mean i guess first before
that i didn't even want to take physics
i took accounting instead and that was
really boring in high school long story
short i switched out of accounting the
only class that would take me that late
in the semester was physics i loved it
and then here i am that's that's the
short story of it but i realized at some
point it was stupid not to go into
physics just because
a lot of my family had gone into physics
and i kind of rediscovered it for myself
and then i made the same sort of
declarative statements against astronomy
while i was in undergrad i was like oh
no i'm never going to become an
astronomer
and here i am
yeah you went from accounting the next
uh major uh alphabetically was astronomy
so
here you are um so on the cover on the
cover of searching for extraterrestrial
life in the audible bookstore
uh there is a picture of an unidentified
flying object a flying saucer shall we
say it looks to be pretty well uh
identified a very very clear techno
signature in the last month alone uh
i've had you know several different
guests on from michael shermer to
uh to seth shostak earlier in the year i
had jill tarter
sarah seeger
what is this fascination with uh uh ufos
as alien craft i mean that seems to be a
pretty big leap in a lot of ways and
then a lot of my listeners right now are
screaming at me no that's the most
likely explanation so a very erudite
audience very diverse but um but tell me
what is it about um about this topic
that immediately conjures up flying
saucers so much so that you have this
very clickable not clickable ahead uh
cover picture on your audiobook of a ufo
when you really spend a lot of your time
looking for microscopic things right so
why is the public so fascinated in
flying soft
yeah i mean great question certainly i
have no input into what amazon puts on
the cover of these things uh but when we
think about these recent pentagon videos
i watched uh your some of your podcasts
on that some of the the podcasts for
example with mick west you know debating
the origin of some of these uh
features and i think
there's a couple things that i think
capture us so one is we really want to
not be alone and so even if we find life
on another planet and it's microbial
life that's that to me is amazing and
that would be just the discovery of the
human
kind however we might still feel lonely
you know if we just find other microbes
on another rock it's not like we can
really communicate with that similarly
if we find even
you know a crow or like something like a
bird we can't talk to that about our uh
you know sort of our
esoteric and
big questions about why are we here and
and how you know how did the universe
begin and all these things we can't like
test our theories against them so i
think we really want to find
life that we can communicate with and so
there is this
uh push to try to
validate and believe i would say we have
this bias it's a bias stronger than the
confirmation bias of course we see what
we want to see that's a very well-known
bias
we really have to pay attention to that
but then there's also the bias of just
believing
what we want to believe to be true and
and so that's also a very strong bias
and i think i think we see that play out
in these trying to identify these aerial
phenomenon because all of them really
have shown to be relatively boring earth
phenomenon uh you know as far as we know
and and i think it's also i would just
say like we we hold these unidentified
objects at a higher level of evidence
threshold than we do for murders you
know we don't solve all murders on earth
but we expect to solve every single
unknown sky i mean that seems a little
bit uh ridiculous to start pinning
aliens on it
yeah i view that as a tribute to science
and our power of science as you point
out you know in the book if you ask the
average american how much does nasa's
you know budget or fraction of it of the
us budget they'll say yeah it's 50 20
uh and it's like less than one percent
as you as you accurately point out uh
but so it's a tribute that they think
that we can answer all these questions i
always say you know science means
knowledge it doesn't mean wisdom and
there's a big difference between the two
and i think part of the wisdom is
knowing the impact of the science that
we do
and i want to take us back to the 1990s
uh when uh you described in the book you
know bill clinton had a press conference
following the discovery of possible
tentative signs of microbial life on
a meteorite from mars that landed in
antarctica
and i just feel you know regret that the
times i've been in an article i've never
picked up a meteorite martian or
otherwise but nevertheless this
particular artifact made headlines
around the world in fact
there's a scene in the wonderful movie
contact
based in part by one of my past guests
andrewian and her late husband carl
sagan uh
where they have in the movie version
they have a press conference where
president clinton's talking about the
discovery of these aliens that ellie
arroway found right and it's so
prominent in people's minds these
discoveries first of all uh i want to
take i want to take two uh aspects of
this question to you pose two
two questions to you one is if we
discover that these were definitively
real microbial life forms from mars uh
it seems to me the impact would be
pretty short-lived because most people
don't know that they've never been
confirmed or refuted right so
as far as most of the american public
knows the same public that believes 20
of our budget goes to nasa they probably
believe that that there was martian uh
dna or some microbial life found right
so 30 years later 20 plus years later so
what do you think would be the long-term
impact if we found microbes versus
finding um you know a techno signature
in terms of a spacecraft or you know or
or radio signal what's the differential
impact between
various gradations of life
yeah i mean it's an excellent question
it's it's something you know as someone
who really wants to find evidence of
life on another planet whether it be
microbial or complex or intelligent
you know i'm staking my whole career on
this this is what i you know
get up you know gets what gets me out of
bed so to speak and and one of the sad
things about this is i think that people
will be underwhelmed when we actually
come up with a discovery because they're
like oh didn't we already discover
microbes on mars or didn't we already
discover microbes in venus or didn't we
already discover you know wasn't it
clear that those alien signals and alien
ufos are real and so i think that people
tend to already believe there is life
and so
despite the fact that we have no robust
evidence for life we just don't none of
the evidence that we have really crosses
that threshold to be considered robust
scientifically
so then
then we should be excited if we do
detect life but i think a lot of people
will have thought that we already
detected that and there's a couple
reasons for that some of it's bias and
media reporting how scientists talk
about things kind of a misunderstanding
of scientific evidence and the
scientific process
but yeah so i think that's one fear i
have is that when we do find
evidence of life it won't be met with
the appropriate ah that it should be for
being one of the most
fascinating and profound discoveries we
could have in our life
and then of course yeah if we can
actually have any sort of technological
signal that we receive
that would be even more fascinating so i
think every scientist alike agree that
that would uh be just all-around more
exciting than
right yeah i always say if you want to
know what it would be like right the day
after the discovery is confirmed
announced and you know at the white
house just you know go down to the beach
and scoop up some some uh water and
there'll be trillions of microbes in
there and uh pretty much people will
kind of move on with their day there are
people that say this would be the most
profound thing to discover microbes i i
tend to think not and the reason is just
look at the history of how awfully we
treat life on earth both animals and
humans right it's just it's just human
history is replete with the denigration
of human life as a value and i think
that's one of the worst aspects of
technology is the cheapening of human
life but anyway finding microbes you
know would be interesting i think to
many people but but you know what would
be the impact the next day it's hard to
say but you did bring up something very
important which is the way the media
cover things and i always have this you
know probably based on my experience
with bicep two and other things that i
talk about in my book uh is this issue
of you know the lead story is always
above the fold like literally above the
fold new york times san diego union
tribune you know toronto star harold
whatever and then the retraction if it
ever comes if it ever comes is on the
saturday edition page b17 nobody knows
about it nobody reads it so
i
claim that scientists should keep a
budget and that some of that budget
should be for pr and some of that budget
should be held in reserve as a hedge
against the risk of retractions and i
think we owe it to the public to not
only trumpet what we think are our
theories and successes uh but uh but you
brought this up and i want to get your
take on it it's so sensational you go
through very accurately and very
delightfully in the book the history of
that martian
uh clean martian uh find and i didn't
know half the stuff i mean
i knew almost nothing i just knew that
it hadn't been confirmed really and that
uh it was probably premature on the
other hand you go through it
meticulously um and i also remember
there was an announcement of uh alien
type life that eats sulfur and whatever
found in mono lake here in california
again these are peer-reviewed things
these aren't just like you know they're
just you know one-off things like
something
they're good scientists you go through
their uh they're they're funny and and
yet so what do we do about that what do
we do about the kind of type 1 verse
type 2 error risk to the credibility of
science that tends to proliferate both
in my field and in your field
yeah absolutely i think
there's a number of things that we
should do and and this is certainly
relevant as we even go right now through
our age of misinformation alternative
facts and false facts and all of all of
this too because
there's a flood of information on the
internet and how to tease out what is
real and what's not is one hurdle and
then a separate hurdle is even in these
prominent publications like you said
they publish the main finding but they
don't necessarily publish the
alternative uh you know updated view
once the scientific community has looked
at it because with any of these claims i
guess if for your audience they probably
know that you're going to have a huge
press release because it is an exciting
discovery it's going to be embargoed
which means a lot of scientists haven't
yet been able to look at this discovery
and then once you put it out you're
going to have a whole bunch of people
think about other things that you forgot
to think about and then it's going to go
through that process of vetting and
maybe it'll be proved to be true such as
the pulsar planets uh you know the very
first exoplanets we kind of forget about
them and i feel sad because they didn't
win the nobel prize even though they
were the first exoplanets discovered
uh you know so we those were eventually
confirmed to be true even though they
weren't believed at the time you know
and then you have other things like the
martian meteor which which hasn't proved
to be true uh but you don't see the same
level of media attention paid to the
other uh parts along that story
so you know i think the venus that we'll
get to the venus discovery but actually
a lot of the
uh
follow-up studies on venus have been
published and i've been and i've seen
them kind of more prominently in the
news so i'm excited about that i think
it allows the general public to see the
process of science and kind of
understand it a little bit more because
i don't want people to come away with
thinking we don't know how to like
nothing's true no study you ever read is
true scientists don't know what they're
doing but i do want them to have you
know some skepticism while also having
that excitement at new discoveries and
retaining both of those things at the
same time
you talked earlier about you know kind
of a working definition of life you
didn't actually make reference to dna or
even carbon-based life you talk in the
book about
these things that have a delightful name
as an acronym but are almost
unpronounceable polyaromatic
cyclic hydrocarbon pah is also known as
pass yeah let's just call them
um but you speculate delightfully about
you know work that's been done that
maybe there could be some version of dna
as schrodinger himself thought some
crystal or something like that later
found to be not accurate but dna instead
but talk about that the alternative life
not alternative facts but alternative
life
um modalities that don't use dna rna
as you discussed in the book you talked
about the rna world hypothesis origin of
life talk about alternative that was
fascinating to me how could pah's past
be candidates for
encrypting and coding genetic
information
yeah i mean any like any molecule that
can link together and contain
information so you could think of you
know in dna we have four molecules rna
also has four molecules so but you could
imagine just like uh like in computers a
zero and a one
that's kind of the basic level of
information and so even if you have just
molecules that can link together and
encode an on off sort of switch it would
take maybe more of them to convey the
same amount of information as say if you
had four switches that you can relay
information through but you can imagine
information being propagated so i think
when we look at various origin scenarios
of life or indeed when we're trying to
find life in our solar system this is
definitely
more applicable to solar system
exploration than exoplanets where we're
more limited by trying to look for
something we can understand but in the
solar system we want to be relatively
agnostic as to the type of biochemistry
it could be and so we want to look for
any type of complex biochemistry it
could not be based in the molecules that
we know so this is
you know going away from pause but if we
look in titan and the liquid ethane and
methane like there what if you had
similar sorts of uh like a totally
different biochemistry there than what
we're used to but if it can transmit
information
back and and support life then that
would be fascinating but we just don't
know yet so so i think we don't yet know
if the phase space of life is open i
would be really surprised if life in the
universe uses dna i think
probably not
but i wouldn't be surprised if it uses
carbon because that's a more fundamental
molecule that's
very common it's a lot more common in
the universe than silicon for example uh
water is likewise a very common solvent
and it has some unique properties so
more common than liquid methane so i
feel like you know water and carbon to
me are more fundamental
units than say dna which is a lot more
complicated and probably wasn't even
in earth's earliest life where you maybe
had rna or precursors to dna like pna or
tna or other information carrying system
systems so when we think about yeah the
sort of propensity to do uh to be biased
and prejudiced as scientists not just
the
invidious prejudice of sexism
and racism that that does uh still
persist in some corners of academia and
science and astronomy itself
and you're a fierce advocate for women
in stem uh you also have the honor of
holding the caroline herschel
she is one of the most titanic
astronomers of any gender in human
history
and here at uc san diego we had margaret
burbidge who also was i believe
overshadowed for a nobel prize in favor
of willie fowler and other people um
and she of course made the fundamental
contribution to the observations that
led to our model of stellar nuclear
synthesis beyond you know sort of the
lightest elements on the periodic table
but when we think about looking
elsewhere and and kind of the bias that
we have towards
what looks like us
as they say not just in terms of our
sociology but in terms of what life
could be um
could phosphine potentially fall into
that because you know the uh the the
paper and so forth the work by professor
jane greaves and cardiff and her
collaborators sarah seeger and and carl
and and others at mit
they are sort of looking you know where
the where the light is in other words
they know that phosphine was a was a sig
bio signature of life on earth and so
why not look elsewhere so what what is
that what is that uh the danger of these
different biases confirmation bias look
elsewhere effect you know the file
drawer effect um you know that that we
suffer from as astronomers as physicists
absolutely i mean first i would say is
in some ways we are for exoplanets again
not for our solar system we are
necessarily hamstrung to look for things
that we can recognize
so it could be that life exists in the
clouds of jupiter for example but if we
can't tell
if that's true in our own solar system
and we've taken high-resolution images
of jupiter with juno
how are we going to see on an exoplanet
we just we just can't even really
comprehend what that biosignature would
be or similarly there very well might be
life under the uh ice cap the ice ocean
on europa
yet that doesn't have an atmosphere and
so as an exoplanet it's relatively
useless to us so i think we need to look
first for global biospheres that we
could
detect and so i think this is a really
common misconception actually in the
public as well as within the scientific
community is when we say habitable
planets it's kind of a short term for
something that we could detect from
light years away it doesn't mean that
that's the only place that life could
exist and we know that you know life
could exist in many other places within
our own solar system but it's just
saying where could we actually have a
hope to detect this from light years
away now all bets are off when we look
at our own solar system because we can
actually go there we can send landers we
can send rovers we can look for this
other type of life
and and so i think um that's where we
should really test out some of these
alternative biochemistries venus is a
great place to look if if such weird
life exists you know same with titan
same with mars europa all of these other
places we should look there because
alternative biochemistries are kind of
if we can't prove them sort of in situ
here in in earth or on planets around us
it's going to be really hard to detect
them on another planet like
and maybe we'll eventually get there and
i think we should keep our mind open so
i really appreciate the work of sarah
sieger and other
colleagues who are trying to be more
open to any type of molecule we can find
but clarissa silva who came up with the
lines for phosphine for example
you know she's
she's trying to go through and create
spectra for more of these molecules but
we don't even have the spectra to detect
them right now there's like 16 000
molecules that earth life could produce
and we only have spectra of even poor
quality for 0.04 percent of them so in
some ways we only are looking for
phosphine because dr clarosousa silva
made the lines for phosphine for example
and then we could suddenly look for it
we couldn't look for other molecules
that we don't have the lines for and
when when you look at the number of
high-resolution line lists that exist
there's just not that many yet so this
is part of the fundamental science that
needs to be done for us to even detect
these molecules in other planet
atmospheres or in the solar system so
talk about let's go deep into what you
actually do
because my audience is the brightest in
the known multiverse and just a reminder
we're talking to a doctor sarah
rugheimer who's got a list of awards
that would take me two or three podcasts
to note uh someday i'd love to talk to
you about the awards that you won for uh
for public understanding and uh for
leadership the rosalind franklin lecture
ship prize in 2019 that was the same one
that the my kid's favorite astronomer
named brian brian cox he won uh you won
you know these these phenomenal
accolades but uh tell me what they're
for is it just for you know doing
something cool what do you do on a daily
basis do you use a telescope are you
looking at spectrographs are you doing
calibration are you building what are
you doing and how can other people
expect to follow in your footsteps how
would they go about following in your
footsteps or doing the type of
day-to-day work that you do
yeah thank you
so what i do is theory so there are
people who are interested in
observations say finding observations of
these exoplanets and i am also excited
about that however we are not yet to the
point of being able to detect
biosignatures and what really gripped my
interest as a scientist is could we
detect life on another planet and when i
entered grad school the answer was this
detection is really decades away and
even still like we're just approaching
the technological horizon where we might
be able to see
the atmospheres of
three habitable exoplanets with jwst so
we're really just pushing that
observational threshold and so what i do
is theory to try to understand
how can we be sure of the detection
how can we think of false positive
mechanisms how
clear would the signal be would it
overlap with other features what kind of
resolution do you need how big of a
telescope do you need so that we can
create future missions these kind of
horizon missions beyond jwst that are
really tailored for
making these measurements so as part of
that i'm part of this life mission
concept in europe called uh large
interferometer for exoplanets life life
and this would be something that could
actually detect hundreds you know or
maybe we're hoping for like 30 50 maybe
100 earth-like planets and characterize
their atmospheres and we and it's also
in the infrared where more of these
molecules absorb so i'm interested in
both
pushing forward this sort of mission
concept which i'm a part of the team for
but then on my research side i look at
how does the star influence our
observations how does stellar activity
influence our observations so i do more
theoretical computational modeling that
hopefully will feed into and make our
telescopes more robust for what we want
to detect
so uh i think if you haven't read andy
weir's most recent book
project hail mary you you'll love it
yeah it's actually yeah and you could
get it like your book uh audible is
actually better than any other way to
get it because it's actually acted out
by a by a phenom by a phenomenal actor
with sound effects etc anywhere uh i'll
put a link to the episode that he was on
on the into the impossible podcast i
thank him for going very deep and we
even got into like mental health issues
and i watched that one yeah why he
dropped out of uc san diego without a
degree and you know he went on to some
success i guess you could say but he
talks about you know obviously he's most
well known for the martian for now
although i think this is even a better
book uh but when we think about uh these
places that people tend to look for life
it's typically been mars
and so lately i want to ask you about uh
two items in the news in your in your
cricket pitch i don't know we'd say
ballpark when you're back in the us
cricket pitch i don't know but anyway uh
the point is uh there's been a lot of
interest in extraterrestrial uh you know
findings including on venus and on uh
potentially on venus and potentially
from
this techno signature that uh your
former you know uh harvard mate avi loeb
talks about in
as a techno signature in his new book um
that we also did an interview with not
too long ago so i want to ask you uh
first of all what is the stat what is
your opinion uh of omua mua and as a
techno signature do you agree with avi
and his 80 papers on the subject it's
not like he just wrote one paper and you
know and then he wrote a book and went
on joe rogan's show and uh and then
afterwards he worked his way up to the
into the impossible podcast but
tell me what is as a professional
what do you make of this of these
right so for remo
i haven't followed all of the recent
articles that have been written on
alternative explanations i'll be honest
i know that many papers have been
published that are more critical of the
finding and i think more importantly is
there is this um
this phenomenon when we have low
resolution data what is it called is it
like the
uh cornelia effect or something like
this we should we could figure it out um
but basically when
there's this there's this famous crater
on mars and it looks like a happy face
and and then when you
yeah and then when you get a better
image of it the happy face disappears
and humans do this all the time we see
things when we have low resolution data
and the data for amulo mua is just low
resolution it's not it's just
the error bars are high we it only had
one pass
we just couldn't get enough information
for it so while i agree with avi that we
should look for more of these and
definitely we should spend some of our
astronomical budget looking for more of
these because if he's correct in the
number of these then we should see more
of them and we should be able to do
better follow-up observations on them
with more time and actually see what
they are
i disagree that it's a strong evidence
of life i think it's more likely to be
some of these other
these other explanations
that um
and it's kind of like looking with the
lamp post under the lamppost i think uh
you know like all scientists we can fall
prey to our favorite hypothesis and then
kind of discount evidence that believes
that so so my my personal uh scientific
view on that is that there's enough
kind of holes in that theory to not
claim aliens it doesn't reach the
robustness of say aliens
uh and and then i would say the same is
true for venus so
uh we
we we don't even
think it might be phosphine you know
maybe it is it's like these these papers
are still coming out back and forth and
the teams are you know analyzing data
new teams are reanalyzing and saying no
it's so2 and then people are like no but
you have an error in your pipeline and
so you you have this back and forth
which is
why science is awesome because it is
prone to falsification you have to
repeat the experiment
and and i you know think that if we do
find you know first off we'll have to
see if it is phosphine it looks less and
less likely it is phosphine there was a
recent paper that shows
uh the water activity in in those uh
clouds is very low and water activity
basically means
could life do the chemistry with water
you know is there enough water there for
it to
be functional and it's a hundred times
lower than any known extremophile life
that we
know on earth so there's a number of
kind of holes that are getting poked
into the venous hypothesis or even just
where is if it is phosphine maybe it's
coming from a different part of the
atmosphere all of these things
matter and so
to me
it's kind of like looking at these ufo
videos you can't just like look at
something fuzzy and be like oh that
looks like a ufo you have to get the
follow-up data or if it is a ufo you
don't necessarily claim aliens i mean
i've seen some weird night uh night
skylights and and then in the end it
just happened to be that the it was a
military plane taking off
near me and it flew over eventually and
i was like oh it's a plane but from a
distance it was doing all sorts of weird
like
geometrical
right angle
stuff and if i you know if i if i wasn't
being skeptical i might have uh claimed
that i was seeing something odd and so
so i think uh the criteria you know the
the same old like the age-old expression
that carl sagan popularized you know
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence and none of these
so far have met that hurdle met that
hurdle
yeah still exciting yeah i always say a
new reference michael schurmer in the
book and he's been on the show many
times good friend of mine
and yeah this kind of believing brain
phenomenon that you fill in the gaps
when there is this uh there is this
noise and and very low signal-to-noise
environment where there's very high
stakes you know it's one thing if you're
like looking for a seagull or as you
talk about looking for a a fly in front
of a spotlight you know it's not going
to probably kill you you might not be
able to see it but oh if you see it if
it's a bat you know we i encountered a
bat the other day and really freaked out
my my kids and my wife but but anyway i
was kind of intrigued by it because
they're so interesting these flying rats
and you don't see them so much in
california but anyway yeah uh but yeah
there's a much bigger consequence i
suppose for that to happen but yeah i
wanted to to bring up this this recent
very provocative you know tweet and and
of course sabina hassenfelder who's a
good friend of mine and past guest many
time guests on the show uh she tweeted
out you know it's almost a sense of glee
uh that the max planck institute in in
germany uh for solar system research and
gutengin
phosphine in venus's clouds no trace
it's pretty rare um like even with the
bicep two affair you might be familiar
might not be but for my listeners you
know we didn't like make a blunder we
didn't leave the lens cap on or like
somebody had a smile we detected
extremely high levels of signal to noise
of b mode polarization and there's no
one's disagreeing with that it's just
how we attributed it what was the source
of it this is now saying it seems to be
quite different it seems to be saying
more in the camp of
almost like the opera faster than like
neutrinos or something like there was
there's actually something wrong with
the original analysis these people are
so area i'm going to have jane on i hope
jane grief professor greaves on maybe
sarasega back for a part two or
something as well
uh but what do you make of this it's
pretty astounding to see
this huge basic flip-flop from you know
scientific community we need more data
to now we don't need any more data and
we probably should focus more effort on
you know other planets go back to mars
you know as our folk as our focus so
what do you think of it this extreme 180
degree flip in the scientific community
not in the public
i mean i think again this is for any of
these claims that are extraordinary you
will get
people trying different explanations and
and trying to redo the data and that's
what you want
i think you have the same sort of
sensationalized uh article journal
article titles after the allen hills
meteorite claim as well and after some
of these other controversies uh you know
i think one of them was like tempest in
a teapot you know i mean so so
scientists can come up with uh you know
very sensational uh headlines on our own
without the media
but i think no matter what
venus is a story that we should pay
attention to because it's certainly a
humbling lesson as we think about
exoplanets
just given the amount of back and forth
on this detection exoplanets are much
further away venus is next door if we
have trouble understanding it how are we
going to understand these planets
orbiting distant stars
but then also you know there are this i
would be curious to see what jane has to
say as well as i'd recommend inviting uh
dr clara susilva who is the theorist and
who's the main person who came up with
phosphine as a biosignature in her from
her phd work
so you know because there are different
ways and polynomial fits to this data
and depending on your assumptions you
can get different results and so i think
that we have to see how this plays out
we know one thing is that the greaves
team has
taken
their abundance estimate down a notch
from the 20 parts per was a billion to i
think one part per billion uh so so
we'll just have to see but they still
think they're seeing phosphine and so it
you know they're it's going to go back
and forth and
whether or not it's phosphine or so2
is interesting and if it is even if it's
a little bit of phosphine that is
unusual and that would indicate some
atmospheric chemistry that we're not
really
understanding or some geological process
we're not understanding because i don't
think it's life
venus is a very hellish world like just
complex chemistry is going to have a
hard time surviving there so so then the
question is what is it if it is just so2
i still think we should go back to venus
because we don't understand venus but
just as a kind of a side note to this uh
colin uh wilson here at oxford
uh said that at a conference of venus
conference they had eight groups take
the same boundary conditions and their
climate models for venus
and with eight different climate models
and every group had a different
atmosphere for venus come out so we just
can't model venus's atmosphere very well
yet we don't understand the dynamics we
don't understand these more thicker
atmospheres yet very well and we're
going to need to as we start looking for
exoplanets so i think venus is
interesting for us
on our way to understanding other
planets no matter what the story ends up
being what the story ends up being
a lot of the books most juicy and
delightful passages that you wrote
again i'm talking with
doctor soon to be professor sarah
wegheimer about her research and her
wonderful book searching for
extraterrestrial life audible exclusive
and you'll see a review there among 70
other reviews uh from yours truly uh
with a with an asterism of of five stars
uh so uh we are celebrating the 60th
anniversary of the drake equation this
year in 2021
and i tried to get frank drake on he's
pushing 90 he yeah he had such a polite
you know declination and declining
rejection i should say of my invitation
it was so polite so classy i love him so
much but i'm not a huge fan of his
equation for the following reason that
you actually point out in your wonderful
audiobook which is that you know we
present the drake equation in a way
that if one of our undergraduates my
undergraduates or future undergraduates
if they were ever to submit a result and
it had no error analysis associated with
it
we would give it back to them with an f
right but the drake equation is always
presented as if you know it's just an
equation it out pops a number and then
you just go on but you point out as you
know if in the book as i pointed out i
gave a talk at the seti institute that
we have to do error analysis as and
that's the hard part of being a
scientist right you talked about the
just the fiend of phosphine life a
minute ago so um but talk about that the
the lack of kind of attention that's
paid to the real meat of what you and i
do which is really in the in the details
of how we look at what as you describe
systematic errors uh in particular and
uh and statistical errors so first of
all what's this what's the systematic
error and how can it play results such
as you know estimates based on the drake
equation right so i mean i think
with the drake equation just in general
when we think about the errors
we really only know the first few
terms with any sort of certainty and
then we're so limited in our
understanding of earth type life in fact
the equation itself is very
astronomy focused if a biologist were
writing this equation it would probably
be different you know and they might
think of different steps that would be
more interesting to put in the equation
so we could just be wrong in where we're
looking for life we could have you know
this bias of
g stars for example we're around a
sun-like star but most of the stars in
the universe are m stars is that a
statistical fluke that we just happen to
be around a star type that's only six
percent of the stars or or is it is
there something there is it that m stars
have some these cooler red stars have
some intrinsic flaw as um habitable
planet hosts so we don't know a lot of
these things and until we get more
observations
of of planets it's kind of like
it seems to me beyond
my imaginative scientific horizon to be
able to pin down the
the terms of the drake equation because
especially like the last term the
lifetime of an intelligent civilization
i mean you could put whatever number you
want in there how are we going to have
some statistical answer unless we have
meet a being that has traveled the full
universe maybe even the multiverse and
we can say give us the answers to this
equation uh i don't think we're going to
be able to come up with that for the
foreseeable future but it's still
interesting i think it's interesting as
a concept it's interesting as a well how
do we try to narrow down uh with a you
know astronomers love back of the order
calculations
could we do something useful from that
and i guess it's these same sorts of
back of the envelope calculations that
turned me away from astronomy when i was
a physics undergraduate student i'm like
they don't know anything to within like
factors of you know 100 or more
and and so
uh
but at the same time now as an
astronomer i do see
some use for it it's just not
it's not the
i think what people might think oh we
can say that there must be millions of
intelligent civilizations in the galaxy
no we have no idea because we have no
idea how common life is how common
complex life is how common intelligent
life is technological life
and how long it lasts i mean we just
have no idea i mean we just have no idea
yeah and i i do want to conclude with uh
sort of a statement that i think you
know your job is made harder in many
ways by the media
as you know kind of this this machine
but sometimes it's even our professional
colleagues who who also take a liberty
and make posters of glias or glissa or
whatever however you pronounce you talk
about in the book these posters they're
very whimsical and but then you know
people start to think like is that looks
really you know photo realistic is that
a real picture of the planet and and my
colleague adam burgasser i'm sure you
know here and he worked on the trappist
results and you know you get these
posters outside their office i'm like
yeah that might be kind of cool to take
a vacation there uh but i think it does
make things pretty hard especially when
you realize that there are so you know
few pieces of tangible physical evidence
and when we get a little bit we just
pour over it and i want to ask you um uh
about kind of the answer to the ultimate
mystery in all of your field which is
the fermi paradox you know where is
everybody but to hear sarah's answers
you're gonna have to subscribe to her
podcast
and my podcast and i'm gonna send out uh
your answers to these questions and more
uh and uh to my mailing list so you have
to subscribe to
brianketing.com my mailing list you'll
get the answers to the thrilling three
questions in which i'm gonna ask sarah
about the her answer to the fermi
paradox and also you can get it by
subscribing to her podcast and leaving a
review wherever podcasts are sold and
that is called self-care with doctors
sarah because you do that with your
friend uh sarah b
uh remind me from remy sarah's last name
again i keep forgetting why ballard
professor sarah ballard
she's at florida yes i want to have her
on too so maybe we'll do a uh
she's coming to the uk in a week so we
could do uh you know
double double sarah's while she's here
for two weeks
she's here for two weeks i think she
introduced me to you in some way or
another uh so for now if you want to
hear the answers to the thrilling three
final questions including where is
everybody in the universe you're gonna
have to subscribe to sarah's dr sarah's
podcast plural professors now sarah
podcast and uh subscribe to
briankeating.com my mailing list so for
now thank you for joining us going into
the impossible with professor sarah
rugheimer thank you
sarah any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
do
[Music]
you